okay the reawaken america tour continues
all across the country this is this sort
of right-wing conspiracy christian type
event it's a weird mix of different
constituencies but very often people
like
former trump national security adviser
michael flynn will speak at the event
sometimes eric trump will speak at the
event and we're going to look at a
couple of clips just to show you uh kind
of the disconnect from reality but also
the kind of level of danger that is
implicit in some of these things we're
going to start first with eric trump
eric trump is not known to be the
smartest of the trump kids but here he
seems determined to prove
he's the least smart saying the real
pandemic in the united states isn't
coveted the real pandemic is fentanyl
take a listen to this so she's supposed
to be in charge of the southern border
you have more fentanyl coming across by
the way the real pandemic in this
country
is fentanyl let's be very clear about
that the real pandemic in this country
is fentanyl it's not covered it's
fentanyl now
fentanyl is a problem and we'll talk
about uh it's a synthetic opioid we'll
talk about fentanyl in a moment
but this is absurd for a couple of
reasons first you hear people cheering
why would people cheer well is it do
they really care about fentanyl no
they care about fentanyl in that it's an
opportunity to say the real issue isn't
covered any opportunity to say that they
love and number two because they
associate fentanyl with the southern
border it's another opportunity to
attack joe biden for what they wrongly
believe has drastically changed on the
southern border since donald trump left
and joe biden came in but let's talk
about using the term pandemic for
fentanyl drug overdoses aren't
contagious in the literal sense now sure
there are trends of drug usage there is
group think there is peer pressure i get
that drugs go in and out of style
but covid is literally contagious
fentanyl is not so to say the real
pandemic isn't the contagious
communicable disease it's drug overdoses
is absurd if a person on fentanyl
sneezes near you
they might give you covet if they also
have it they're not going to give you
fentanyl overdose now in terms of
numbers if we look at deaths by cause in
the united states in 2021
you see that last year 415 000 americans
died of covid and 71 000 americans uh
died of fentanyl so it's about one-fifth
the number now it's a major issue for
sure i'm not diminishing the crisis
around fentanyl uh we we have to
understand that not only is it a small
fraction of the death relative to covid
uh that we also need to consider the
legal status of drugs in making that
number as high as it is well what do i
mean
part of the issue many fentanyl
overdoses and
overdose deaths
are people who aren't even trying to
consume fentanyl they're accidentally
taking it because of how people obtain
drugs in the united states because of
the criminalization of drugs right the
war on drugs has a big role to play
sometimes fentanyl is added to cocaine
sometimes fentanyl is uh used in pressed
pills meant to look like
oxy or other opiates
sometimes it's put in all sorts of
different drugs that people are getting
so
you could dramatically reduce fentanyl
deaths by treating drug addiction
as a public health matter rather than a
criminal matter which the american right
is very uh unwilling to do so on four or
five different levels just off the wall
bonkers here is eric trump here's one
just like a bonus clip
this is kind of funny and sad i guess a
trump one flag started to be unveiled in
the background and eric trump says it's
the greatest flag better even than the
american flag i guess
i love the carolinas you guys are the
greatest and honestly when i came here
and i saw
raise that flag again over there that's
the greatest flag
wow
[Applause]
trump won it
there a single person in this room that
thought that joe biden won the last
election
and neither do i guys
neither do i and our country is an
absolute mess right now i mean it is
guys we dedicated our life to this
mission believe me we're the last family
in the world that needed to get into
politics right we have so much money the
last place i ever really needed to be
was here with people like you in fact
most of my life i've been spent i've
spent trying to stay away from people
like you but we did it by choice we did
it by choice delusional and the crowd
cheers let's look at one more clip from
this event